welcome back to CBS mornings where of
course you know U.S military support
plays a key role in Ukraine's fight to
defend itself from Russian aggression
but this morning we're learning how
everyday Americans are also stepping up
to protect Ukraine's most vulnerable
we're talking about children children
who lost their parents or who've been
separated from their families they've
been turning to a safe haven called the
city of goodness MTS tayab shows us how
this orphanage has gotten help from
Americans people like you to meet the
growing need
they say take it takes Village to raise
a child
Western Ukraine it's a city
this is the city of goodness
where around 200 children who are either
separated from their parents in the
chaos of war or orphaned in Russian
attacks have found a safe place to call
home all are cared for here including
infants kids with disabilities and many
with serious health concerns
[Music]
Martin levchenko founded the facility
three years ago it was meant to be a
refuge for women and children escaping
domestic abuse and still is but Russia's
invasion of Ukraine changed everything
overnight you went from a shelter a
place for women and children to find
safety to an orphanage how did you do
that
foreign
the war changed all of us she says I
never dreamed that within the city of
goodness's walls there would be orphans
but suddenly we had one orphanage come
to us for help then the second then the
Third
did that any
time you think I don't know if we can do
this I don't know if we can help so many
yes every day every day I worry but if
we can't make lunch or what if we can't
buy medications or pay our staff but
every day there are so many wonders
happening around us we receive donations
from Americans and people here in
Ukraine who make sure that our children
are taken care of well fed and protected
the donations particularly from
Americans have been nothing short of
transformative since the start of the
war over a year ago the city of goodness
has been able to build two new buildings
with a third under construction even a
fire engine was donated by a sponsor
from the U.S all the funds go towards
helping Ukraine's orphans including
helping them to find forever homes
something Alexi and Irina hope to give
little Master this is the first time the
husband and wife a soldier and school
teacher are meeting her what was it like
meeting her for the first time I cannot
express my feelings with words Edina
says
levchenko says she hopes to find homes
for all 200 orphan children here and
plans to welcome at least 150 more this
building which was paid for by American
donors was built not only to house
orphan children but also to keep them
safe from Russian attacks
so this is a bomb shelter yes this is a
bomb shelter make with love of love with
love for children yes this is great
playground
children our kids very love this place
they don't care they say oh great we go
off to bomb shelter
it's incredible the city of goodness is
no doubt very special
how important is it to get donations
from Americans who have supported you in
in such a big way already
thanks to our donors from America our
children have everything they need she
says and with their help we can care for
even more children
at astounding level of support for
Ukraine's most vulnerable
for CBS mornings I'm in fiestaib
intranetsky Western Ukraine
whoa whoa good to see they do tummy time
even they're always good